madame monsieur bonjour et bienvenue en
bourgogne bienvenue en direct sur le
plateau de la voie est libre plateau en
configuration électorale puisque dans
cinq semaines maintenant aura lieu le
premier tour des élections
départementales nouveau scrutin nouvelle
configuration pour reconstituer ce que
l'on appelait jusqu alors les quatre
conseils généraux de la région et qui
deviennent les quatre conseils
départementaux alors quels sont les
enjeux de ce scrutin
nous allons en débattre avec nos quatre
invités alain suguenot bonjour vous êtes
le député maire de beaune président de
l'ump de côte-d'or
jérôme durain bonjour jour sénateur de
saône et loire et secrétaire fédéral du
parti socialiste de ce département
edouard ferrand bonjour député européen
et secrétaire départemental du front
national dans l'yonne et enfin philippe
hervieu président du groupe europe
ecologie les verts au conseil régional
de bourgogne beaujolais à la maison je
vous rappelle que vous pouvez réagir
poser vos questions par le biais de
twitter hashtag élevé bourgueil watts f3
bourgogne sur notre site internet
bourgogne pour france 3 point fr ou via
notre page facebook
alors pour ces départemental les
prétendants avaient la possibilité de
déposer leur candidature jusqu'à lundi
jusqu'au lundi prochain 16 février et on
le voit sur ces images
ils ont été déjà très nombreux dès lundi
matin à l'ouverture des portes des
bureaux d'inscription de la préfecture
de côte-d'or à se précipiter donc pour
déposer leur candidature un premier
bilan peut-être de ces candidatures à
gauche comme à droite alain suguenot il
y à des dissidences que comme on dit il
y en a plusieurs en saône et loire y en
a plusieurs en côte d'or il ya des
querelles dans la nièvre et des
querelles dans l'yonne est ce que vous
êtes déçu et ce que vous attendiez à une
plus grande unité retrouveront pour le
co2 en tous les cas y'a pas trop dit si
la droite part sereine il ya tout louis
je crois qu'il ya toujours des velléités
on sait bien dans des actions comme
celle ci mais je pense que les électeurs
ne veulent pas des bagarres de petites
chapelles donc ils veulent effectivement
qu'on ait un vrai projet puis surtout
des candidats qui ont déjà fait leurs
preuves et qui ont envie tout simplement
de bouger des lignes comme on dit donc
je crois que non tout le cas en ce qui
concerne la famille politique à laquelle
j'appartiens il n'y a pas eu trop de
difficultés
à gauche il ya aussi des dissidences
gérante est notamment au thym dans votre
département ou c'est pas toujours très
facile
est ce que ces désaccords rendre le
combat encore plus difficile parce qu'on
sait que le contexte national n'est pas
femme particulièrement favorable pour
vous ce ne sera pas mon avis si
difficile que ça le département de saône
et loire du point de vue l'unité des
socialistes puisque après les
sénatoriales ont organisé le
rassemblement
tout le monde est rentré sous la coupe
de la majorité départementale
effectivement il reste un compte au
tournoi où il ya de candidature sinon je
crois qu'on a un dispositif politique
qui est assez homogène
après ce que rassemblement avec les
autres forces de gauche on en parlera
peut-être tout à l'heure c'était plus
difficile que nous souhaitions
on va en parler effectivement edouard
ferrand des candidats dans tous les
cantons bourgogne vous confirmez mais
chez nous c'est l'unité effectivement la
grande nouveauté c'est que nous aurons
des candidats sur tous les cantons de
bourgogne et donc je crois que c'est un
grand élan un grand élan qui est née
avec l'élection de partielle du doubs
qui va montrer que le front national est
une force politique majeure en bourgogne
voici la force montante en bourgogne et
donc nous allons créer la surprise parce
que je pense que nous allons être
présents dans un certain nombre de deux
cantons au second tour et donc nous
ferons le jeu politique et c'est vrai
qu'il faudra compter sur le front
national pour cette élection vous êtes
déjà dans la grande région voulait tout
fait partie d'un manga mais bientôt
grâce aux socialistes mais bon je pense
que vivacité de bourgogne reste aura
manifestement à l'asteras la goana
grandes régions économiques les grandes
régions culturelles et une ferons en
sorte que la bourgogne ne soit pas le
parent pauvre de cette fusion philippe
hervieu emmanuelle cosse disait qu'il
irait un tiers de candidature autonome à
thiers d'alliance avec le ps un tiers
avec le front de gauche est ce qu'on
retrouve cette configuration sur sur
notre région
oui on retrouve à peu près cette
configuration pour ce pour cette
élection on avait décidé de laisser de
mettre en place le principe de
subsidiarité de laisser les groupes
locaux décidée au plus près du terrain
pour savoir quel était le meilleur façon
de faire progresser l'écologie sur le
terrain dans l'est sur le concret du
terrain et des territoires
on va y revenir mais c'est facile à
expliquer ça aux candidats
aux électeurs que l'une formait avec le
ps il faut aller contre en tous les cas
nous ce qui nous intéresse c'est de
faire progresser l'écologie alors c'est
vrai que ça dépend du territoire
l'écologie elle est pas allé pas au même
niveau partout à l'epo au même niveau
dans les villes les contacts sont plus
difficiles dans les campagnes donc on
est obligé d'avoir des ajustements par
rapport à ces contextes l'a donc du coup
ça donne effectivement ddd cas de figure
un petit peu différent parfois nous
partons tous nos propres couleurs
parfois on s'allie avec le parti
socialiste comme sur les cantons du
jeûne est une impression pour tous
peut-être avec cette question de véro
sur internet il ya des grands cantons
des candidats qui sont très peu connus
est ce que les gens ne vont pas voter
finalement surtout pour l'étiquette
politique ce qui n'était pas forcément
le cas avant pour les cantonales
ce survivant sinon ce serait oublier
temps d'élections nationales gens que le
contexte est ainsi fait ce avec le
découpage le nouveau découpage est très
complexe et très très aussi faire en
tous cas n'aurait pu éviter ça je crois
que on avait à l'époque nous ont mis en
place une réforme territoriale qui
permettait diminuer le nombre des
représentants départementaux les
conseillers généraux de l'époque mes
conseillers territoriaux déjà et c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui on se retrouve en
côte-d'or a pas d'économie 46 au lieu de
c'est absurde surplus vous avez en effet
raison il ya des cantons immense j'en ai
notamment de ma circonscription avec 92
communes un territoire qui fait presque
60 km de long c'est que les électeurs
risquent d'y perdre donc il va falloir
faire de la pédagogie pour apprendre et
c'est vrai que le scrutin national est
important aussi parce qu'il faut savoir
si on veut donner un blanc seing au
gouvernement aujourd'hui dans la
situation actuelle je crois que c'est
l'occasion ou jamais de s'exprimer jean
vira je ne suis pas certain que ce soit
la dimension nationale qui l'emportent
nous on se les voir on a vraiment choisi
de d'avoir la bannière de la majorité
départementale très forte majorité qui a
bien travaillé dans les mandats
précédents donc je pense que ça va être
important avec un scrutin pour lequel
moi j'étais j'avais quelques prévention
au départ misant ce binôme à ce que ça
va bien marcher
il a quand même de grands avantages ce
mode de scrutin d'abord la parité
effectivement partout
on aura des candidates femmes puisque
l'allemagne est obligée lui femmes comme
ça c'est quand même un vrai progrès
deuxième avantage et c'est ce que nous
on a vraiment cherché à jouer en saône
et loire du côté de la majorité
départementale
on peut marier l'expérience en sortant
avec la nouveauté avec la fraîcheur
militante
on craint pas la chute ainsi des degrés
divers on peut vraiment marier dans ces
binômes expérience et rajeunissement
donc ça c'est plutôt intéressant
oui carrière effectivement ce mode de
scrutin il ya du bon et du moins bon le
bon c'est qu'effectivement il va faire
progresser la parité dans cette
collectivité quel conseil général et
qu'un a véritablement besoin quand on
regarde la photo aujourd'hui du conseil
général de côte-d'or que je connais bien
il ya vraiment besoin de la parité quel
rabat près partout dans une autre chose
qui est bonne aussi et qui a pas rappelé
jérôme c'est que on a maintenant des
cantons qui sont plus équilibrée en
terme de population auparavant on avait
quand même des disparités qui allait
pratiquement de 1 à 5 à 6 à 7 par
rapport à des comptes en pouvait se
faire élire avec mille voix donc il y
avait vraiment un problème démocratique
las ce problème là bas va être réglée
alors c'est pas le scrutin que nous on
aurait rêvé on aurait rêvé d'un scrutin
à la proportionnelle notamment une liste
départementale à proportionnelle ski
régler le problème de parité est aussi
le problème de démocratie à l'intérieur
du département
pour répondre à votre question initiale
je pense que l'on est dans un national
isation des scrutins de plus en plus
fortes on l'a vu il ya encore quelques
presque un an avec le scrutin municipal
où on avait beau être un bon maire mais
comme on était un bon maire de gauche et
mais on était on sortait on sortait du
jeu je crois qu'on est de plus en plus
dans des scrutins nationaliser avec des
enjeux nationaux je crois que c'est un
petit peu l'air du temps avec la vitesse
de circulation des informations
c'est difficile de faire autrement et
c'est et c'est regrettable pour revenir
sur le mode de scrutin peut être et de
l'art ferrand j'imagine que vous avez au
moins un point d'accord avec monsieur
c'est sur la proportionnelle dont vous
l'auriez souhaité nous aussi non parce
que le front national est capable
aujourd'hui dont la fille que le scrutin
du tout dalet d'arrivée en tête
non cette réforme territoriale cet
aménagement du territoire tel que
proposent les socialistes est une
catastrophe
la droite il est pensé déjà avec le le
rapport balladur
moi je pense que contre et on va
éloigner le citoyen du centre de la vie
politique
c'est une dégénérescence de la
souveraineté populaire et je crois qu'il
faut sanctionner justement ce
gouvernement socialiste qui est mis en
place un système qui est fait de
clientélisme qui fait de caste qui est
fait pour sauvegarder les intérêts des
petits copains et moi je crois qu'il
faut profiter de ce de ce scrutin pour
imposer une nouvelle politique faire en
sorte que les français soient remis au
coeur de l'action politique est là qu
est ce qu on voit on voit qu'il ya une
opposition entre la ruralité et les fils
on voit qu'à une fracture dans le monde
rural et moi je pense qu'il faut
justement faire en sorte que ce scrutin
soit l'occasion pour les français de
faire un vote de sanction et de dire
aujourd'hui
stop au système impose ont maintenant
une nouvelle dynamique celle du front
national
jantes du rhin on va élire
c'est l'une des critiques que l'on
entend beaucoup on va élire des
conseillers départementaux finalement
dont on ne connaît pas encore allés les
prérogatives
est-ce que c'est pas paradoxal ça quand
même parce que finalement la loi notre
n'a pas encore été définitivement
validée par le par leur sort était plus
confortable d'avoir les compétences
final je vous la corde avant le scrutin
globalement c'est à peu près les arts
est le point d'arrivée d'allouer un
autre c'est la nouvelle organisation
territoriale de la république et le
premier ministre manuel valls est
exprimée dans le sénat
quand nous étudions texte en confortant
les départements en disant qu'il serait
assigné aux compétences de solidarité
sociale et solidarité territoriale donc
effectivement le détail des compétences
n'est pas connu enfin en gros on sait à
quoi les on va finir on va les aider
faut souligner non aujourd'hui vous avez
fait c'est un aménagement du territoire
sans recevoir ce qui avait dedans
les ennuis commencent avec monsieur
ferrand je crois vous dites vous dites
je vais les rangs des choses qui sont
fausses sur la fracture justement le
département c'est l'échelle aller voir
les serveuses sociales et territoriales
sauvé deux jours ces discours au sénat
vous aurez le droit c'est ainsi que de
la conception de la démocratie c'est de
ne pas laisser parler les autres parce
qu on sait que vous en voyez déjà aux
journalistes on l'a vu vous menacez tout
le monde
les six mois comme une hausse qui donc
moi je pense qu'effectivement le rôle du
département avec des régions qui sont
plus grande qu'ils sont plus stratège
c'est d'assurer sa solidarité avec une
bonne continuité entre l'urbain et le
rural ces deux cents à nouveau conscient
quand on sait le sens des compétences
que les départements vont exercer et on
doit avoir un aménagement du territoire
qui fonctionne bien avec s'est soulevée
l'équipe et d'affaires non mais les
socialistes ils font du clientélisme
c'est à dire qu'il s'occupe uniquement
de la politique de la ville les
territoires ruraux sont les grands
arbres donner de la politique régionale
bourguignonne est aujourd'hui besoin de
vous faire croire que vous allez faire
et de solidarité les départements il
cela est d'arrêter sur quoi la seule
chose que vous avez réussi à faire c'est
justement éloigné toutes ces campagnes
de des sites urbains et moi je dénonce
aujourd'hui justement le fait que
aujourd'hui on bocog il y à une
superposition du millefeuille
administratif alors que nous on défend
l'idée de la commune du département et
de l'état
et là on veut nous faire un magma de
politique régionale en faisant en sorte
que le département soit le parent pauvre
de l'organisation des collectivités
locales et faire en sorte que le citoyen
ne s'y retrouve plus et je dénonce
aujourd'hui justement cette manoeuvre du
parti socialiste qui essayent
aujourd'hui avec les départements de
reconquérir son électorat
mais au lieu de leur au contraire il va
y va l'affaiblir et va montrer qu'il ya
de plus en plus d'inégalités aujourd'hui
en bourgogne
mauvaise réforme on est tous d'accord
là-dessus qu'effectivement les
territoires ruraux sont les abandonner
de ces histoires et au surplus on l'a vu
avec une représentation sur
représentation notamment de dijon en
côte d'or et des villes en particulier
sous représentation des territoriaux et
c'est vrai que c'est quand même la
première fois qu'on va élire des élus
territoriaux sans savoir vraiment ce
qu'ils vont faire et de ce qu'on sait
aujourd'hui la loi notre travail travaux
des commissions c'est purement et
simplement le millefeuille qui aurait
fallu dénoncé je pense que cette réforme
ne va pas jusqu'au bout où on ne faisait
rien ou effectivement et à ce moment là
il fallait redonner des éléments qui
permettaient d'éviter de mille feuilles
on va continuer à séparer de nouveau les
collèges et lycées probablement on va te
donner les mêmes compétences aux
départements que celle qu'on lui
reprochait hier est probalement les
mêmes compétences aux régions donc c'est
une aberration aujourd'hui quitte à
faire une réforme autant la faire bien
et aujourd'hui cette réforme n'existe
pas on va élire pour rien début et c'est
vrai qu'il va falloir bien évidemment à
mon avis politiser cette élection pour
montrer aux françaises et aux français
qu' on va dans le mur et il ya des sur
le chômage ya d'autres prérogatives
savait que pour l'instant c'est un
espèce de rideau de fumée qu'on est en
train de faire à travers ces élections
il n'empêche qu'il fera bien sûr ce
exprimé la crainte que j'ai c'est que
les françaises et les français se
rendent pas compte de l'intérêt
politique d'aller voter
il faut bien sûr les mêmes chansons et
pas par rapport à cette réforme là c'est
pas effectivement par rapport à la
réforme départementale qu'on va
mobiliser bien évidemment les électeurs
ne vous a pas entendu nous on était
persuadé qu'il fallait une réforme
territoriale de grande ampleur
malheureusement cette réforme là bas
nous convient pas trop considère qu'il
fallait rapprocher le citoyen de la
décision que de la décision politique
c'est pas le cas on se rend compte qu'on
rajoute des couches au millefeuille
puisque ont créé des métropoles dont je
crains qu'elle faisait aussi des
prérogatives qui viennent heurter celle
du conseil régional notamment en matière
de développement économique
je pense qu'il y avait vraiment quelque
chose de beau et de grand à faire parce
que je crois qu'aujourd'hui on voit bien
qu'il ya un problème démocratique il y a
des gens qui se déplacent de moins en
moins pour aller voter
et ça je crois que il fallait prendre le
taureau par les cornes pour mixer deux
choses d'abord mettre plus de
représenter 2 il fallait mixer la
démocratie participative avec la
démocratie représentative à l'intérieur
même
des régions il fallait généraliser le
scrutin proportionnel
et puis il fallait aussi ré furent
réformer le mode de fonctionnement des
collectivités locales aujourd'hui quand
on est maire ou quand on est président
du conseil régional
on est à la fois patron de l'exécutif et
patron de l'exécutif du délibéré hâtif
et ça c'est pas bon je crois que il faut
voir il fallait véritablement mettre une
coupure entre les deux on voit ce que ça
donne on l'a vu à notre dame des landes
on l'a vu à 6,20 200 le voile on l'a vu
à roybon et on lave on a peut-être le
voir ici aux rousses et avec
l'installation d'un centre d'un santerre
parc c'est à dire que quand un président
de conseil général ou conseil régional
décide quelque chose il le fait voter
immédiatement et ça passe alors qu'il
faudrait quand même consulter les gens
pour leur demander leur avis sur ces
sujets là on l'a vu aussi dans le morvan
avec le projet arrière tu heureusement
on s'est arrêté mais il ya véritablement
besoin de démocratie une démocratie
supplémentaires dans ce pays
si on veut pas que les gens
s'abstiennent et puis si on veut pas que
ben ils se disent lily vote pour le
front national contre lequel évidemment
qui a des beaux jours devant lui parce
qu'effectivement comme la démagogie
c'est bien la manipuler voilà il
faudrait en plus le voir à l'oeuvre des
stupéfiants c'est ça oui après on va
axer sur le sur le point du rousset je
vous rappelle quand même que rémi
chaintron s'est engagé à ce qu'une
démarche de concertation piloté par la
commission nationale du débat public sur
le roux c'est donc on n'est pas dans
l'exécutif l'autoritarisme le passage en
force on est dans une concertation donc
pas de souci sur ce dossier là juste un
mot sur la fracture que dénoncer tout à
l'heure monsieur ferrand je crois qu'il
faut arrêter au front national de se
faire passer pour la nouveauté on peut
amplifier toutes les colères surfer sur
toutes les difficultés sociales ça fait
pas une politique
moi je m'occupe à la région
l'aménagement du territoire je passe mon
temps à organiser la solidarité entre
les territoires locaux et les 10 centres
urbains 70% ses fruits de la région
c'est d'être les villes et pas les
campagnes mais s'il a que 30 % pour les
camps three faut aujourd'hui un
mouvement inverse les gens par des vis
pour s'installer dans l'excès parce que
vous parlez elle
las des autres et pour nous mêmes nous
aimons plus de retrait vous n'avez plus
tard quand vous êtes au bout de votre
logique et moi je crois que c'est le
temps justement qu'on change c'est elton
politique en bon dieu quelles nouveautés
qu'elle joue bien alors on n'est pas
madame irma ici mais essayons de voir ce
qui va se passer notamment par rapport
au contexte national et de la politique
nationale on a vu la remontée de
l'exécutif dans les sondages après les
attentats de même il ya eu ce succès
diplomatique qui reste à confirmer bien
sûr on en saura un peu un peu plus ce
soir d'angela merkel et de françois
hollande à qui se sont retrouvés à minsk
mercredi là on envoie quelques images
avec le président russe vladimir poutine
président ukrainien pour auch enhco
alors est ce que tout ça ça va jouer
selon vous est ce que c'est vraiment à
la marge que les gens vont aller mettre
leur bulletin de vote
philippe hervieu moi j'ai évidemment le
contexte international va jouer beaucoup
il ya un sentiment de 2,2 et puis le
contexte économique va aussi beaucoup
joué aujourd'hui on se rend compte qu'à
une embellie le cac 40 a été à plus 10 %
par rapport à au début janvier 2015
il a jamais été aussi haut que depuis
depuis 2008 on a un prix du pétrole qui
est au plus bas on a des taux d'intérêt
qui sont très bas on a un euro qui est
descendu et donc qui permet d'avoir une
monnaie compétitive au plan
international donc je crois que les
choses ne sont pas jouées pour les
départementales savait un peu court pour
que tout ceci puisse avoir une influence
je pense que pour les régionales si on
continue dans cette dans cette voie là
et je pense qu'effectivement le contexte
à la fois géo politique mais aussi
économique peut jouer en faveur de son
maintien d'un bon maintien de la gauche
dans les régions je craque pour je
pourrais peut être faire des plaisirs
échouèrent vieux mais je crois que les
français de n'imagine pas la situation
de la même manière entre la vitrine y
compris du mois de janvier ce qui se
passe ce qui s'est passé à minsk
quand on voit le sourire de poutine très
honnêtement s'inquiète je crois que
cette embellie très limitée dans le
temps pour des raisons très médiatique
du président de la république et du
premier ministre est en train de chuter
très largement dans les sondages parce
que les français qu'est ce qu'ils vivent
yves sur le terrain d'une part
effectivement de mauvaises réformes on
vient d'en parler ils vivent également
le chômage yves les difficultés du temps
je souhaite moi aussi qu' on puisse
réussir
simplement parce que les petits messages
plan d'arrondir on va gagner parce que
le pétrole baisse parce que l'euro
baisse très nettement on va gagner grâce
aux autres je crois qu'il faut
aujourd'hui en france plutôt dire qu'est
ce que peut faire le gouvernement pour
essayer de sortir d'une situation dans
lesquels on continue à s'inscrire qui
est une situation d'échec
donc si on veut réussir je crois qu'il
faudrait à mon avis était terminée faire
des réformes et ses réformes las c'est
pas non plus la loi macro qui va le
permettre
non je crains en tous les cas que les
françaises et les français dans une
élection qui va se dérouler maintenant
dans un mois ne soient pas dupes de
cette situation et je le dis pour mes
voisins socialistes ou écologistes
il n'empêche que je pense qu'ils sont
d'un optimisme qui flaire à mon avis
quelquefois d'ailleurs un peu se tromper
véritablement sur ce que donneront ces
élections bientôt et j'ai peur cependant
que les français à ce niveau là soit
ceux des affections vision qui serait la
pire des choses travers une abstention
c'est le moment ou jamais parce qu'on
leur donne la parole de s'exprimer soit
effectivement bas vote quelquefois un
peu un vote de désamour par rapport à la
cause politique qui pourtant est la
seule aujourd'hui qui permettrait
peut-être de redresser la situation
jean behra vous disais tout à l'heure
que la majorité n'était pas en bonne
posture enfin la dernière élection c'est
quand même pas nous qui l'avons gagnée
dans des circonstances complexes dans
les eaux dans le doubs l'ump a
complètement disparu des écrans radar la
stratégie sa conception a toujours été à
gauche toujours mais ce regard des
chiffres
vous verrez effectivement que c'est
beaucoup plus nuancée que ça et que la
réalité c'est la stratégie de sarkozy
d'aller siphonner les voix du fn s'est
retourné contre lui et que vous êtes
dans une tente une impasse politique
moi ça ne me réjouit pas ça ne me
réjouit pas parce que on a du travail de
fond à faire dans ce pays et ont fait on
était il ya quelques jours
en saône et loire avec thierry mandon
qui travaille à la simplification
alors ça c'est pas spectaculaire mais
c'est du travail de fond qui va servir à
nos concitoyens dans leurs rapports avec
les administrations aux chefs
d'entreprise pour faciliter toutes leurs
démarches
c'est cette politique là l'image du
travail de fond qu'on en fin de de
réaliser
avec françois hollande et manuel valls
moyer des choses qui ne me satisfont pas
complètement je voudrais qu une
orientation un petit peu plus social
je pense que les réformes démocratiques
elles doivent aller un petit peu plus
loin mais je pense que ce travail de
fond il va payer et malheureusement les
gens autour sort que le président de la
république nous disent ah oui mais le
contexte est difficile et un homme peu
su répliquer sur les 600 milliards de
dettes de sarkozix et pas nous
donc je pense que le fn qui essayent de
surfer les 608 chose en crise depuis
deux ans et que la pauvreté les
difficultés économiques et sociales qui
sont réelles en proposant des solutions
qui sont complètement archaïque avec
d'ailleurs l'appui de monsieur poutine
pour david souter puisque c'est la
russie qui finance le front national
avec des élus qui ne sont ni meilleurs
ni nouveau contrairement à ce que dit
monsieur ferrand c'est une impasse
politique
donc du coup la période difficile ont
fait un travail de fond qui est ingrat
mais moi j'ai bon espoir que ça paye à
la fin notamment pour les gens qui sont
le plus en difficulté alors il doit
faire un référendum
on a vu quand même que le front national
je peux me répond dans le doubs il a su
à l'honneur sur les thèmes
j'ai quand même pouvoir parler un petit
peu si vous voulez ce matin parce que
quand même beaucoup de choses à dire
vous sentir leur tandem c'est quand
j'entends le discours monsieur du rhin
le discours du parti socialiste mais
c'est lamentable c'est creux jeudi ils
ont pu rien à dire ils ont échoué
complètement et je pense que les
français vont ouvrir les yeux pour cette
élection
les deux sujets majeurs aujourd'hui qui
seront au coeur de cette élection c'est
l'insécurité et l'immigration
l'immigration parlons sans vos sujets
sur le sujet bon je peux parler monsieur
valls a décidé aujourd'hui de faire
venir 60 personnes de calais pour les
installer dans une chambre est
désaffecté à pouilly-en-auxois
c'est ça la politique d'immigration du
gouvernement des chants qu'ils sont sans
papiers qui vont aller dans les tétons
euros c'est le gros remplacement que
veut faire monsieur valls l'insécurité
par l'ensemble la sécurité l'insécurité
dans les campagnes allez voir
aujourd'hui tous les vols qui vient dans
le matériel agricole notamment
allez voir aujourd'hui cette insécurité
qu'on a constaté malheureusement avec la
sphère du 7 janvier l affaire charlie
hebdo
la sécurité c'est 30 ans de laxisme de
la gauche et de la droite moi je dis
stop
et je pense que les français notamment
les bourguignons ont nos mains de cette
immigration qui maintenant atteint nos
territoires ruraux et son homard cette
insécurité qui se développe de plus en
plus dans les campagnes
donc voilà je pense qu'aujourd'hui il ya
deux ans je maximum qui va falloir
justement mettre sur le sur la table
c'est l'insécurité et l'immigration dire
cette politique qui depuis 30 ans
justement compris pour les élections
départementales dont a priori le
conseils départementaux n'ont aucune
compétence mais vous les connaissez les
compétences du conseil général y en a
aucune les socialistes n'avaient laissé
sionistes ont été incapables de produire
une loi de proposer un véritable
aménagement du territoire
donc moi je vous dis aujourd'hui voilà
il faut sanctionner cette politique
cette politique depuis 40 ans nous a
conduit droit dans le mur alors monsieur
dur a dit on sort sur les problèmes mais
qu'est ce que vous avez fait depuis
qu'il est au gouvernement
vous avez fait qu'augmenter le justement
le le chômage on est passé de 100 à 110
millions deux cent dix mille chômeurs en
bourgogne à 125000 c'est ça ce que vous
avez fait c'est ça votre réussite de
politique alors aimé un peu plus de deux
raisons dans vos propos parce que je
crois qu'aujourd'hui les français
justement c'est de plus en plus
difficile pour eux m ce n'est que la fin
de mois comment souvent le début de mois
ici en bourgogne
c'est pour ça que la sécurité
l'immigration c'est vraiment pas les
sujets centraux raison les questions de
sécurité sont des questions qui sont au
coeur des préoccupations de nos
concitoyens et on devrait plus 1 103
occupée le problème c'est qu'on a vu que
quand ce sarkozy était au pouvoir il a
je crois diminue les effectifs de la
police et de la gendarmerie de plus de
6000 personnes
il a éliminé toutes les actions
préventives justice de continuer toutes
les actions et des postes ils ont recréé
des postes et toutes les actions
préventives qui sont au coeur de la
lutte contre l'insécurité et qui ceux
qui sont menées par des associations à
l'intérieur des quartiers etc ont été
abandonnées donc je crois que maintenant
si on est dans le climat dans lequel on
et ce n'est pas par hasard
en tous les cas ce que je voulais dire
monsieur ferrand ce n'est pas en
décidant que les armes sont nos amis les
armes sont nos amis comme vous l'affiché
à béziers via monsieur ménard
mais dire que les armes sont vos amis
c'est pas correct et surtout vous
engager la discussion sur une pente qui
n'est pas la bonne je vous le dis de la
même manière que votre représentante
dans le dos et papillon elle fait
campagne
oui quand elle fait campagne sur le
péril islamiste je suis désolé monsieur
s'est jamais d'accord c'est vrai
occuperait de vous pour vous dire et des
choses pareilles les armes ne sont pas
nos amis il n'y a pas de péril islamiste
en france alors
par rapport à ce vote front national
quand même là on a vu alors il ya un
chercheur en sciences politiques à
l'université de picardie qui s'appelle
jouer le combat qui a vu qui selon selon
ses calculs dont curé à peu près la
moitié des électeurs qui ont voté ump au
premier tour qui ont voté front national
au deuxième est-ce que ça ça vous
inquiète ou est-ce que vous vous devez
de finalement ceci est ce que vous vous
dites que ben ils ont plutôt voté à
gauche en général candidats bourguignons
ça va beaucoup plus loin que ça est ce
que vous pensez qu elle vraiment une
porosité maintenant trouver retraités ou
alors le je pense effectivement il ya
plus électeurs de gauche aujourd'hui qui
la situation dans laquelle désormais
aussi bien le parti socialiste que
d'autres familles de gauche par
désespérance vote en effet pour
nationale c'est clair l'ump par essence
sont pas simplement des militants il ya
des électeurs et je crois que là-dessus
nicolas sarkozy avait raison j'étais pas
favorable au ni ni moins en ce qui me
concerne je suis pas non plus favorable
au front républicain parce que ça fera
une aberration aujourd'hui de dicter
effectivement risque on dit aux
électeurs en leur dit que les amis sont
dans une démocratie que chacun est bien
sûr à même de faire ses choix et c'est
bien sûr aux militants et aux élus que
nous sommes de dire clairement quelles
sont les conséquences des choix et je
pense que le parti socialiste
aujourd'hui une grande responsabilité
parce que l'échec économique dans lequel
on ait abouti pour non seulement à des
votes de désespérance et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un peu ce qui se
passe alors que le front national
apporte les vraies réponses certainement
pas qu'ils posent des questions
probablement image au pour lesquelles
monsieur sud nous d'aller partout à
travers je terminais ce que sa mère est
simple appel à voter socialiste non 6e
aurait soudain je suis en désaccord
total avec aussi bien valable que tu
sautes brisach dessus juppé je pars est
alors nicolas sarkozy qui dit clairement
les électeurs sont majeurs et dans ces
conditions c'est la raison pour laquelle
on dit qu'il avait été mis en minorité
sur le ni-ni mais je crois qu'ils
avaient raison je crois qu'on l'a vu
d'ailleurs les électeurs ont leur dicte
pas un vote aujourd'hui de s'exprimer
par rapport aux difficultés du temps par
rapport à ce qu'ils vivent sur le
territoire et je pense que c'était un
vote majeurs dont le candidat socialiste
a été vue parce qu'effectivement c'est
une circonscription socialiste depuis
toujours
description ambitieux moscovici le front
national a répondu tout simplement par
un vote de difficultés de désespérance
et qui a permis tout simplement bien
évidemment est ce qu'il ya un
rapprochement dans le cas des élections
très honnêtement l'ump n'a pas appelé à
voter ni pour les uns pour les autres je
crois que c'était une fille du mans
la juste on pouvait difficilement
soutenir le gouvernement que l'on
critique même par rapport à ses récents
de situation dans le sud nous à l'ump
parce que ça veut dire que si vous
n'appelez pas à voter socialiste quant
au deuxième tour il ya un 2e tour front
national parti socialiste ça veut dire
que le parti socialiste ne votera pas
pour vous comme vous serez face au front
national peut pas appeler à voter
jusqu'à tourner en désaccord avec la
politique du falcon fait la nique le
jacquet actuelle vous rendez bien compte
que vous vous exposez à la même chose
dans l'autre sens à mon sens ce on
s'expose j'appelle les françaises et les
français
la ville de vote en conscience et
s'abstiennent c'est un peu le mot 2 il
ya un vieux jeu de mots qui dit dans le
dos on s'abstient mais il n'empêche que
c'est effectivement ce qui devait se
passer sur ce département et les
français sont assez majeur les électeurs
du doubs pour voter pour qu'ils veulent
c'est ce qu'on appelle chez nous on
interdit de nourrir de la parole on lui
donne la parole aux l'autorisent comme
un mouvement positif par définition si
vous électeurs sont majeurs pour voter
pour lui et j'allais on en reparlera
cinq minutes environ juste après le
flash présenté par les ériger à tout de
suite